Tổng thống Mỹ đô nân Trump, tuyên mố sẽ điều động lực lượng về mình cuối xa đến thành của Memphis,
bằng chimisi, để đối phó với tình trạng tổng phản bạo lực léo thang.
Để lập quy định tiếp nối sau vệ chính quyết liên bằng tiếp quan lực lượng cạnh sát của đô Washington và Tháng Chức.
Đồng thái chưa từng có chung liệt sự hiện đại Mỹ.
Theo số liệu của cuộc đều tra liên bằng A B.E.
Memphis là một trong những địa phương có thể lệ tổng phản bạo lực cám nhớ,
với zân số vật phản sống trong mời mùi gình gây.
Tất cả này, các trăm chăm khi tổng kê của cuộc đều tra dân số trấu thấy
có các một phần tư dân số Memphis sống dưới mức nhau,
đất đồ tỷ lệ trụ mình tọn quốc.
Tổng thống chóam cũng đệ ngọt hả nâng chiến khán nhân tư liên bằng
đến nhiều Orleans và Chikka Go.
Các bây giờ, đều lên tiếp này và nếng nỗ lực mạnh tay,
nhằm khó phục ăn những đô thiệt.
Sống đồng thời cũng đặt ra chân luôn về dưới hạn,
các tiê của chính quyền liên bằng tại các tiệt phương.